okay now i kind of alluded to this right
at the start but i think part c is maybe
the hardest part and i've got good
grounds to justify that because you can
see it's got three marks attached to it
right so obviously the exam committee
thought there was the most work involved
in this part by itself anyway so how
we're going to do this
it says use integration by parts on the
integral in part b so
here is the integral in part b right
here
and i might just
duplicate that because we want to keep
it in view black so
use integration by parts on that
in in order to show that and then we've
got the first introduction like so far
we've been dealing with a n
and so you can see that on the left hand
side but this is the first introduction
of the bn term so there's bn and there's
bn minus one
now i need to obviously know where i'm
working toward so in a very similar way
do you see how in part a just going back
here you can see how i'm like oh i need
to get an a n minus 1. so i wrote down
what a n minus 1 was so it was very
clear what direction i was headed in i'm
going to do exactly the same thing with
my b n terms so that i know where i'm
working towards let's do this in red so
what's b n b n is by definition from
naught to pi on two and it's very
similar to a n if in that you've got the
cos to n x d x but the single difference
is that there's an x squared there also
in the integrand right from there it's
fairly straightforward to say therefore
bn minus 1 is going to be all right
what's the same
boundaries are the same the x squared
term is independent of n and then you've
got cos 2n minus 2 same trick as we
pulled before x dx all right so i need
to uh think about how i'm going to get
towards these from this a n term uh you
know that's going to appear and i'm also
going to like they've told me explicitly
use integration by parts on this okay
so what i notice is that like i
highlighted it before the thing that's
special about bn is that the integrand
has this extra little term hiding in it
it's got an x squared term in both the
bn and in the bn minus 1. so if i want
to get to an x squared term they've told
me to use integration by parts the x
squared term is going to appear either
by differentiation or integration i keep
on posing this question because it's the
core question underneath how you choose
things appropriately for you and dv
have a look at the result uh from part b
have a think about whether what in this
integrand is going to lead me to an x
squared and i am going to get there via
differentiation or integration
hopefully you can see with cluedrin
enough to know that you're not going to
get to an x squared term by
differentiation and that's because to
differentiate down into x squared you're
going to need some x cubed term right
and there's nothing like that in the
integrand and you can't manipulate it
easily to make one right
what there is instead is i'll highlight
it in green
there's an x here which we can integrate
up into x squared in fact
they made it even easier for you as it
were because there's a 2 hanging out the
front there so that 2x is going to
integrate up directly into the x squared
that i need in both bn and bn minus 1.
okay so what that tells us is all right
i think i can write my bn integral in
such a way um that it makes it easy for
me to work out um the 2x and that'll be
my dv so then i can work out what my u
and my d u r okay
all right
so um just because i'm slightly lazy i'm
not going to keep on writing that um
n at the front i'm just going to say
consider not in dotted lines
i'm going to say consider
uh let's see here the integral of not
from not upon to of i'm going to pop
that 2 into the integrand like i
mentioned before so it goes with the x
and then i've got the rest of it which
is sine x cos of 2 n minus 1 x dx okay
what am i going to do with this right
well i'm going to do my u and my d u and
my
dv and then my v okay
maybe i'll do this in slightly reverse
order because um i chose my dv based on
it being right uh here
right so uh that'll make things easy
you'll see why in a second i'm sort of
leaving the undu for a minute so i'm
gonna go uh i tend to write this in the
in the bottom so i'm gonna go let's
leave some space dv on dx if we choose
that as being 2x that clearly indicates
that v will be equal to x squared so
thumbs up so far
now what does that leave as our u and
you're like oh this doesn't look very
good right i'm going to get everything
else here it is sine x cos 2 n minus 1
x so in fact if i just grab that here
keep it in green so i can see it as you
keep it in green so i can be consistent
with everything else i've done by
integration by parts you're looking at
this and in any other circumstance you
would say
hmm i think we've made a mistake right
because you're like oh no even the
differentiation is usually easier than
integration i've got a product here
right you've got this times this i'm
going to have to use the product rule
okay now even though that sounds
horrendous and it will also look
horrendous there are clues in the
question that i'm going to refer to in a
second but just let me bring the
question back into view just to signal
it for you right there are clues in the
question that even though this is going
to look gross
you should stick with it
and it shouldn't be discouraging to you
that it is initially terrible okay here
we go
i'm going to go with my um
if i choose my my u and my v
it's going to be tricky because i've
used u and v to integrate my parts i've
got a different u and v in my head what
i'm going to do is with
this term times the derivative of the
first term right so therefore
i would normally think of this as
v times u dash but it's a different v
and a different u okay there you go
there's the first part of the product
rule and then i'm going to um
add uh the uv dash right now just be
super careful here okay in this case um
the the v dash right is going to be like
one of my oh i forgot an x there that's
a bit cheeky isn't it or did i move it
over i forgot to move it up anyway
doesn't matter let's neaten that up so
it's reasonable to read there we go
um this is going to have a minus sign
attached to it right because my inside
function
here i already differentiated this which
gave me cos i'm going to differentiate
this the inside function is cos x you're
like oh my gosh i'm using chain rule
inside product rule okay so the inside
function being cos x its derivative will
be minus sine x
and then you also have another sine x
there right so then when you put them
together you're going to get minus of
sine squared x i hope you're seeing
where that's coming from it's two places
i've got a minus sine x from the inside
derivative here and then i've got a sine
x from just writing that function as
part of product rule okay so that's that
part done
and then i have to say well what else is
there i have the outside function of
this which is something raised to the
power of 2n minus 1. so the power comes
down at the front front as it were i'm
already in the middle of this term and
then the power reduces by one like so
okay so i've used the product rule and
the chain rule inside here but i'm still
not done yet right because as we've seen
before you've got a sine squared term in
there and what i'm heading towards is is
b n terms none of which have sine
squareds in them or signs at all for
that matter okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
use the pythagorean identity again and
that's going to allow me to have like a
cos squared term in here which is going
to do some simplifying over here if i'm
very very cautious okay so let's have a
go at this
let's just write out the pythagorean
identity so it's going to go this stuff
hasn't changed because there's no signs
in there
and then here let's just i'll do it this
way like i did before here's the sine
squared it's going to become 1 minus
cos squared and then everything else
there just hangs out
on the end okay
still gross but stay with it please
don't let go um i've got um when you
have a look out the front here um i
should have i don't know why i didn't
write this in the first time these two
terms are going to collapse together
because they're both close terms right
that's a cos to the 1x you're going to
add their indices so that's just going
to give you
cos to the 2n x actually i know exactly
why i didn't combine them it's because i
was focused on this gross thing over
here and then i'm going to multiply this
in through by the cos 2 n minus 2 x
because all these cos terms are going to
come together i'll leave that 2 at -1
there's no reason to expand that
binomial because look back that 2 minus
1 is right there right there's no point
like if it's going to appear factorized
you might as well leave it factorize
there okay
all right so we get a minus
leave that 2n minus 1 there like i
mentioned before and then what happens
when i multiply through well
1
times cos to the 2n minus 2 x that's
going to be cos to the 2n minus 2
x
and then does this look familiar cos
squared look at the indices the 2 and
the minus 2 are going to cancel so
that's going to give you
let's see here just be careful with your
signs minus
cos
2 n
x all right
now i said before this is going to look
terrible
before it gets better it's still looking
pretty horrendous even after i took this
initial chain rule inside product rule
simplified it with a pythagorean
identity and also expanded to have as
few terms as i could
it doesn't look pleasant
but i'm actually really encouraged by
what i've got based on the fact two
things number one i've got the x squared
here that i need for my bns right see
there's my x squared i needed them and
there was kind of no other way to get
that then by choosing this 2x as my dv
on dx so there's the first clue the
second clue is even though this is long
and gross it's long and gross in exactly
the way that i want
what does that mean we'll look at the
result we're required to prove there is
a 2n minus 1 well that looks good right
and then there's a b n minus 1 and a b n
b n minus 1 and b n well where are those
here's that b n minus 1 that i wrote
earlier so i could keep it in mind and
you can see the dna of it is right here
right there's the cos the 2n minus 2 x
and once i combine it with that x
squared term from v i'm good to go right
and in much the same way this cos the 2n
x over here will contribute to a bm so
even though it's long and gross it has
all the pieces that i need for this
result that i'm required to prove okay
so i just have to be patient with it
when i combine it it should all come
together okay
all right so
i've done integration
by parts all the components anyway so
let's bring that line of working over
here and let's combine the jigsaw puzzle
okay what have i got
this is equal to all right here comes my
my u and my v so in this case i'm going
to get my x squared and then
let's see it's this term up here isn't
it that term right there duplicate that
bring it down
that's the end of my definite integral
it of course like everything else goes
from naught to pi on two and then i'm
going to subtract my v
d u okay so let's have a go here
i got my v so that i would have x
squared all right thank goodness i got
it and then here comes the d u and
you're like okay yeah this this looks
terrible but i'm gonna have to stick
with it i'm just going to write the
whole thing here let's grab that if i
got enough space
i think i'll just oh you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to cheat a little
bit and just make the whole thing a bit
smaller there we go yeah sorry you can't
do that with your working on your piece
of paper all right so all of that that's
there in green that's um i should put
big brackets around it because it's all
being multiplied by the x squared that
you can see at the front of the
integrand and it's all integrated with
respect to x that's why i need to
squeeze it in a little bit okay
so let's you know walk through this one
step at a time
um for starters and i'm not even going
to write it again i'm just going to you
know sort of point to the fact that this
uv definite integral
this thing in here which i'm going to
put down in there in orange the same
thing that's going to happen to that as
all our other definite integrals it's
going to evaluate to zero because of our
specific
upper and lower boundaries okay so that
put that to one side
and then let's kind of step through this
one step at a time so i'm just going to
turn this back into black so i can
highlight over a little more easily i
just hope you remember that all of this
came from my du
on dx it's just that that other dx is
hanging out over here to cancel it
anyway let's step through this one at a
time in fact maybe i will write this as
i go just because there's so much to
keep in your head okay
i've already got this 0 hanging out the
front here
then i want you to look carefully at
this x squared times cos to the 2n x
what is that well if you look carefully
back to the start that is just on its
own that's bn right right there so
therefore if you have a look i've got a
minus an x squared cos 2n the x it's not
multiplied by anything else integrated
with respect to x so therefore i can say
that's minus b
n
okay that's good
then i've got
watch out here there is how can i
highlight it for you let's put it in
with this this negative this negative
and the 2n minus 1. so the double
negative is going to cancel and the 2n
minus 1 is a constant coefficient i can
pull out of the integral altogether so
i'll go plus not with a highlighter
plus
2 n minus 1. okay that's looking good
and then what comes on the inside like
i've got the rest of this
here which i sort of already identified
as giving me a bn minus 1 here
and then a b n right there
so therefore i'm going to write those uh
let's just use that red color okay i'm
going to say well that's going to give
me the b n minus 1 and it's a minus sign
isn't it b
n there we go okay
it looked awful but because they defined
bn for us in this way you can see how
it's all collapsed down into this very
nice and succinct notation so that's
very promising okay
now
you can see here a whole bunch of things
are going to like cancel out for me
right so this is going to be equal to
i've got a minus b n hanging out the
front
and then i can sort of expand out here
in order to let me collect like terms
between these two bn's here right i'm
going to leave this 2 n minus 1
factorized for the b and minus 1. reason
being go back to the result we're
required to prove
there it is right there see that b n
minus 1 it's attached in factorized form
to a 2n minus 1 so you might as well
leave it right that's good but the 2n
minus 1 that's attached to bn that needs
to be expanded so that i can collect
like terms so let's go ahead and do that
what have i got here so i've got just be
careful with your negatives i've got
minus 2 n
lots of bn and then i've got
plus
you can see there i've got the minus 1
the minus 1 and the bn just a single
bm right there okay so you can see uh
this kind of split apart like so
i've got a minus bn out the front and a
bn at the end so they're just going to
cancel with each other like so
and what does that leave me with well
you can see i'm going to have
let's see here so it's going to be 2 n
minus 1
b n minus 1 and then it's going to be
minus 2 n
b n okay so this is promising right i've
simplified down as far as i can really
with these terms i'm pretty close to
what i'm required to prove what you need
to remember is well what is this thing
actually equal to let's just squeeze it
over so i have a bit more space where do
we start all the way up here i consider
this object right so i'm going to take
that
copy it bring it back down here
here we go
okay now
what can i do with this thing well you
can see that if i
take this left hand side right what it's
equal to where it came from was that
it's a n right see that
all the way there in part b a n is equal
to this but i included the 2 to combine
with the x and i didn't include that m
right so what i've got is missing a
factor of n so it's not a n it's a n
divided by m right so therefore i can
say here we go
um this thing here i can say from oopsy
daisy from part
b that's where i got it um that whole
left hand side integral is not a n it's
a n divided by n yeah so that's going to
be equal to i'll grab drag the equal
sign with me
that's going to be equal to that and you
can see here you're like oh wait a
second what's the thing i'm trying to
prove um on the left hand side the
subject is not a n on n it's a n on n
squared right like i'm right there so
all i need to do is take everything you
can see here and divide through by n so
let's go ahead and do that
i'm going to get
a n on n squared on the left like i
needed
this term here 2n minus 1 that will
divide by n and it leaves me with a bn
minus 1 and then the n that i'm dividing
by will cancel by this end that's here
so therefore i just have minus 2
bn
and that's it i can say as required
it's hard to remember because it was so
long ago this was the result that part c
was asking for and yeah that was a lot
of work that's why this is the question
that attracts the most marks to it
because you have to choose
your integration by parts carefully you
get this horrendous result here i think
this is what accounts for the fact that
even though we're getting we're doing
integration by parts so many times it's
it's not worth three marks anywhere else
except for here and i think it's because
that's gross um but as you can see with
patience you land on the result that you
are required to prove